all right let's get to what's going on
in the national football league and we
expected this
chris last week when the nfl suggested
it would allow
teams to gather in groups of up to 10
for the draft and then people started
saying to me wait a minute how does that
comply with the stay-at-home orders that
are now in place in most states well it
doesn't and i asked the league that
question and they never answered and of
course they don't like to answer the
questions that are going to entail them
saying oops maybe we got over our skis a
little bit on this and they did so the
end result no one is going anywhere for
the draft everyone will be at home a
virtual draft announcement made by
commissioner roger goodell yesterday in
a memo sent to all teams in response to
developing conditions and the advice of
medical and public health experts clubs
have been advised to prepare to conduct
the 2020 draft entirely outside of their
facilities and in a fully virtual format
with club personnel in separate
locations and able to communicate with
one another and draft headquarters by
phone or internet we want all nfl
personnel to comply with government
directives and to model safe and
appropriate health practices see there
were two issues here as i see it chris
number one
you have to comply with the stay at home
orders and unless you can get some sort
of dispensation in every state where the
nfl does business because now missouri
finally has caught up with the rest of
the free world and shut everyone down
every state where the nfl does business
has a stay-at-home order
uh number one you got to comply and you
got to find a way around it if you can
and obviously they couldn't and secondly
it's about it's just a bad look
everybody else has to work at home the
nfl isn't entitled to any type of
special treatment and also it sends a
message like if it's you you either
comply right or you spend your time
trying to come up with ways to get out
of your house and ways to do the things
you want to do well no the whole idea is
stay home if you can in any way shape or
form stay home so it's a good example
the nfl setting it's a smart thing to do
it's the right thing to do and i applaud
them for realizing even if it came six
days too late that they can't pull this
off by allowing club officials to
congregate yeah it's the right thing to
do i mean honestly mike i think
sometimes you know you you writing
letters to the league
us talking about it on the show almost
helps them come up with like hey we need
to formulate a plan people are going to
start talking about this and we got to
figure it out so
you're amazing at that that's the first
thing i wanted to say okay that's enough
of the content it doesn't make it no no
no it doesn't matter
that's enough yeah you're still in that
athlete but whatever but yeah i mean
you're we've been talking about this
from the get-go right mike i mean hey
there's people tuning in to nfl coverage
on a daily basis they look at these
people as leaders people they look up to
if they see jerry jones and stephen
jones and mike mccarthy in a meeting
room it might embolden certain people to
say oh what's the big deal i'll roll up
i'll roll the dice and go over my
buddy's house that over over uh across
the street and it's only two of us we'll
watch the draft together whatever it may
be so yes it's the right thing to do by
the nfl it's good to see they have
formulated this plan and you know
ultimately mike i don't know if it's
gonna hold you know throw
huge hiccups
uh as far as what teams need to do on
the day of the draft you know other than
a few circumstances here and there but i
think you should be able to run business
as usual you know with these you know
teleconference digital video sessions
yeah i mean the key is planning for all
potential contingencies rehearsing
practicing having an idea of how the
labor will be divided who will be
responsible for talking to which teams
about possible trades you just need to
have your network in place and you need
to have one conductor who's in charge of
everything to make sure that all of the
various tentacles are doing what they're
supposed to do especially as the time
approaches to being on the clock there
is a concern though that john harbaugh
the ravens coach pointed out yesterday
and i think we've brought it up in the
past the possibility that
someone could hack something that
someone looking to gain an advantage can
find out what the ravens are talking
about or some other team are talking
about by maybe slipping into their their
zoom teleconference and video conference
undetected and you know look
we know enough about the way the nfl has
operated over the years to assume that
someone will try to
develop an advantage in this situation
not just merely take care of their own
business but push it a step farther and
try to interfere with someone else's
business and i hope if someone gets
caught doing that they get the biggest
punishment we've ever seen because never
the time to try to exploit the situation
but chris do you think this is a
legitimate concern the team should be
worried about i don't think it is you
know i i think that's being a little
paranoid i understand i mean you want to
cross every t dot every eye make sure
you're secure here and information is
not getting out i understand that so now
maybe you know he puts that on the radar
of the nfl once again here to where
maybe they can find out some system
where they have security checks here
through this whole thing however it may
be but you're right i mean that would be
the low blow of low blow to do something
like that during these times when yeah
things are not normal and you you might
not have all the the normal checkpoints
in place let alone we've had some
political issues with you know
and that's become a topic of our our
culture anyways to where let's just stay
away from that topic anybody in the nfl
let's not hack into anybody's system and
try to steal information so you know i
don't look at that as a big deal mike
the one thing that jumped out to me
right away just because you know hey
i've been in new england during draft
day i've i've walked into tampa you know
during draft day uh a few times as a
player there just to check it out you
know here's one aspect that really kind
of jumped out to me you get into the
middle rounds of the draft fourth fifth
sixth round sometimes you got guys on
your board that are so close right mike
let's say it's running back a and
running back b all right they're really
close and you're going wow
we're getting close here to pick 110 and
both of these running backs are going to
be available to us hey let's throw in
the tape real quick and watch 40 plays
of each guy and let's just talk it out
and see what we want to go with you
might lose that aspect here with the
video conferencing in the draft where
you know hey hey pete carroll and john
schneider and a few other scouts they
all want to talk and compare two guys
right that they're really close on the
board now that may become difficult with
the video and you of course not going to
have the film accesses be able to
everybody to see and kind of discuss the
player and the positives the negatives
of that that was one thing that jumped
out to me right off the bat
but if they have a setup where they're
all communicating
right couldn't somebody pop up the play
and they all could see it i mean this
gets into chris what what every team
needs to be doing and should have been
doing it all along because look anybody
who was paying attention to this knew
there was no way in hell it was going to
be a normal setup that everyone was
going to be at home so the teams that
spent the time identifying and this is
what i said the nfl needs to do
generally but the teams the smart teams
would be doing this specifically
identify every what if every wrinkle
every angle here's what we ordinarily do
in the draft room how do we simulate
that here's another thing we ordinarily
would do in the draft room how do we
simulate that and you've touched on
something very basic very simple very
important and the smart teams and i'd
like to think all teams are smart enough
to figure this out we'll come up with a
way to
allow coach gm whoever else has their
hand in the stew to look at some
last-minute film of this guy versus that
guy as they try to decide which of the
two they're gonna take when they're
finally on the clock
yeah you would hope that that would be
in place and you know again i'm not mr
technology but i you know our the teams
have the foresight to
maybe
have a more impressive improved type of
teleconference system to where they
could link it up you know from the
coach's house to you know the pro
personnel to the gm guy you know better
than maybe a zoom i'm saying something
more even high-end that way the teams
have the foresight to maybe get ahead of
the storm there and set that up i i
don't know you know but again i just
think it's going to be a hell of a draft
for a lot of reasons um you know and and
the other thing too mike you know i i
think there's not too many cooks in the
kitchen for too many teams i think when
we see a draft day rooms more times than
not yeah we see a lot of people in that
room but more times those people are
really just there to enjoy the scenery
and be a part of it but as i experience
that ever saw like in tampa or new
england as i talked about there's only
four or five people that are talking on
the day of the draft everybody else they
might as well be when i was in new
england we were all watching on tv
outside the draft room we didn't know
what was going on we were just reacting
like all the other fans whoa we picked
him i can't believe that what are we
doing right i mean that's truly what we
were doing because it was the pro
personnel the gm the head coach the
owner maybe the head of college scouting
and that was all that was it and that's
really all that needs to be involved for
the most part
in these video conference calls when it
comes to the draft unless you want to
call maybe an area scout just to get a
little more of a inside tidbit on the
guy's personal life off the field
yeah i think that it it creates a an
urgency and i think a wisdom
to take the various people who are
there to do a certain job and and give
them a specific task and know when
you're going to call on and basically
that's why i said you need a conductor
you need somebody who knows we need this
here's who we go to we need this here's
who we go to instead having a room full
of people and just shouting out can
somebody find x you know in advance
who's responsible for that you know in
advance who's responsible for this and i
think the look again the smart teams are
going to find a way to do this the right
way they're creative they're organized
and they're going to get the thing put
in a right spot for them to get the most
out of this experience right a couple of
other things that came out of this memo
that weren't expressly said chris first
of all it's obvious that the
commissioner is going to be at home he's
not going to make the trip to espn or
anywhere else to a tv studio it screams
out from the text of this memo even
though he doesn't say it there's no way
he can leave his home when he's telling
everyone else connected to the nfl that
they have to stay in their home and
secondly what also screams out from
between the lines of this memo when you
consider the acknowledgement that many
of these stay-at-home orders now extend
into june and the idea that everyone has
to be on equal footing you can't have
different sets of rules for different
teams i think it's just a matter of time
before they tell us there's no off
season program whatsoever and we'll see
everybody when it's time to show up for
training camp whenever training camp
opens
yeah i think we're we're at that i think
a lot of you know listen
my friends that i talk to in the nfl
right now mike you know that they don't
expect this to be a normal season i
think they're all looking at it right
now just hoping that maybe we can get in
to start training camp mid late august
and that it's going to be a shortened
season i don't think anybody is really
expecting things to be totally normal
hopeful optimistic wishing for it sure
but things aren't normal and you know
what peeped him a little lighter lighter
lightest right one of our producers
there he made a good point and this is
going on to what you said about the film
and
being able to you know compare a player
here and there i know frank reich had
publicly made comments lately that he
was holding some some coaching meetings
through zoom with his with his coaches
to to draft evaluate and i know that's
going on around the nfl too so you know
to your point yes that should be able to
get done then if you had a complainer to
compare two players that were very close
on your board and you want to make one
final look and one final decision
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports